bing-bang-boom bow hey what's going on
YouTube no I don't need to tell you what
this is about now do I with some respect
did you did you pull up on Ross that way
or Trick Daddy now I'm pulling up on you
[ __ ] yeah I'm the radio guy walked off
with the radio guy hey my new bird man
now probably about a week late with this
but I don't give a [ __ ] because they
should maybe left so hard now you
already know when it comes to today's
society
nothing is [ __ ] sacred you got to be
careful about what you say in these
public forums now about a week go on
Twitter Instagram and every other social
media that you could think of I kept on
saying the word arrests back and I said
to myself well what if Lucky's about but
apparently this worker was going around
because Birdman had a very
confrontational interview with The
Breakfast Club where he was telling them
that they should put some respect on his
name I'm gonna tell you Berman as an
artist I've never really been that big
of a fan but you talk about a troll
goldmine the moment you said that
made-up word you just asked the Internet
to spread your butt cheeks and [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out you because number one what the
[ __ ] is respect you have been on this
earth for how many years looking like
Smeagol tan cousin and you still don't
know how to say it respect my brother
you want respect you got to first
pronounce it right I mean my god there
was a song about it Holi is pinky I bet
you so confused when you heard that song
you try to Microsoft autocorrect that
[ __ ] didn't you it's RESP ECC wait what
is that that's not it and what the [ __ ]
was this about what's with the whole
thing with you coming in and sitting
down and crossing your arms like a
five-year-old child no mo I ain't gonna
say no mo you say anything you just said
something that sounded like the word
respect how you gonna come to a radio
station
sit down and say you have nothing to say
for a radio interview that makes no
sense
ain't nobody gonna take you seriously
with your Shanti sunglasses let me ask
you something else how you gonna
threaten somebody when you can't even
chew gum and talk at the same time I
wanted to see you I want to talk this
[ __ ] spit out his gun like a 70
year old man you ever seen an 80 year
old dude spit out gum that should never
come out smoothly a [ __ ] her car huh
and you know what one of the most
annoying things about this interview was
was how Birdman
reacting to opposition and the responses
that he was giving every single [ __ ]
thug or ghetto person has to do this I'm
talking about what somebody asks you a
question and you respond with something
that has nothing to do with the question
so Charlemagne in the interview was
basically asked to him why did you come
here and sit down if you didn't want to
share or say anything at all and his
answer was I mean it's all good but I'm
saying why I'm here was I'm all good I
did it already what's happening oh my
god what does that mean you are not
answering the question when you answer a
question with a question that means you
know you [ __ ] up I'm saying why did
you come if you were upset and you
weren't gonna say anything
I'm already here what's happening okay
but why are you upset I'm already here
what's happening I understand you're
here why are you upset I'm already here
with that what the [ __ ] are you saying
and don't even get me started about this
response right here y'all done y'all
finished all y'all done mr. Behrman in
case you didn't know those two phrases
are synonymous burn man is known for not
liking to do interviews I used to think
it's because you know he didn't like all
that drama [ __ ] I just think it's
because you don't have a grasp of the
English language now and by the way this
is coming from a dude that wasn't born
in the States
I'm over here on the sidelines correct
in your [ __ ] English it's not a
perfect English sheet and after saying
your piece is saying you could have
[ __ ] up Charlemagne at the club but
you were a man
so you decided to confront him on the
radio station while not saying anything
at all you'll walk out with your goons
all pissed off the childish to be honest
with you I don't know if anybody could
take you seriously with those ridiculous
chains and that flea market dragon
sweater you going on personally as an
Asian man every time I see a dude wear a
sweater with some [ __ ] dragons on it
it makes me die on the inside and if
that's what he didn't have dragons on it
my bad still I [ __ ] hate it stop it
but question to y'all what do you guys
think about bird man's reaction do you
guys know why Birdman was so angry in
the first place cuz I don't [ __ ] know
number three even if its anger was
justified do you think he handled it in
the right way a lot of people saying
David aren't you afraid of burn man
aren't you afraid he's gonna kill you he
put out this video yes I am mr. Birdman
please don't kill me I love you this is
just this is just entertainment Oh David
you a [ __ ] yeah I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] I
told y'all are you trying to die it's
just for comedy
hey what's going on YouTube yes that was
a topics submitted by y'all multiple
times if you guys want to suggest more
topics to on that Facebook fan page I'll
read that [ __ ] message me on there and
then you can even go on the instagrams
or on the Twitter's follow that [ __ ]
love y'all [ __ ] don't suck dick
unless you want to and it's your
preference this is getting weird
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo why burn man's head
look like one of the missing dragon
balls and [ __ ] no wonder Goku couldn't
find it it was on a rappers head